October 1997 brothers Jose in hey-zeus
novus of Spain are out to conquer the
mountain cameraman Alejandro Rocha stays
behind to film their attempt odds are
one of the brothers may not make it home
tons of fresh snow cling to the mountain
steep slopes Annapurna is now a ticking
time bomb
the brothers forge ahead anyway soon
they are mere specks in the distance
as Alejandro films his worst fears come
true
a colossal torrent of snow and ice
crashes over the climbers avalanches can
reach speeds of 80 miles per hour
this one is thundering straight towards
alejandro
he can't bear to face his killer he
retreats to his tent this is the face of
a man waiting for death
but miraculously the massive avalanche
grinds to a halt just a few yards from
Alejandro's tent his life has been
spared but what about Hosea nasals no
one responds they could be anywhere
under the snow trust by the Avalanche
were buried alive
Alejandro searches with his camera for
any signs of life
suddenly he spots something on the side
of the mountain he can't believe his
eyes an overhanging ledge has protected
Jose in hey-zeus as the avalanche
steamrolled over the brothers are
thrilled to be alive